I miss Sally miss saggy tits
yeah I'm sorry I miss her bring back
Sally
oh you don't you don't know that's so
nice wait I can't pick up stuff okay
okay
I'm so excited for this already why do
your rounds always start with that we're
different
O'Reilly we're space troopers oh cool
your sash and troopers shut up
cuz you're not so what do you think
happens if we step into this check ah
good Oh up into it or nothing okay
I always promise star game I think now
is the perfect time I'll reenact one of
our fan fictions purple bulbous body
approached my yellow we don't have
flashlights we just talk this time I
gazed into markup eyes eyes yes and I
gazed in the yamimash his lack of eye
because his creature does not the floor
is wet yes
well thanks yamimash you purple cabbage
for giving away my confident even hear
what he said wait I think Marcus a mop
bucket or something but yeah yeah go
with that logic go down that route and
that's correct
I know I do i things are on the
companion cube gray that's are you still
there wait that's a century oh no I
can't I can't no clip god dammit yeah
we're just Helen are you I don't know
this map is huge I have no
maybe they're here you don't know how he
is now fight us inside an hour is what
the hell
this door is broken open sound doesn't
do anything yes a poster of Morgan
Freeman
yamimash come to my oh hey okay
alright it's me and yeah me yeah don't
don't kill me whatever you do you know
the love that we have is too intense for
you to kill me so please spare me this
[Music]
[Laughter]
is the worst shot in the history of our
own Hey you are the worst
no I can't bad but that's beside your
that you're the worst murder oh that's
true yeah one shot here you get 1000
connection problem there we go come on
come on all right - I was taken aback
oh all right so I feel like you can be
really [ __ ] cheap on this - jack is a
fish yeah you could be a fish and it's
so [ __ ]
Jack where'd you go check where'd you go
I'm here I'm here where are you are you
are you here
splish-splash we were taken up where are
you I'm are you that well-camouflaged oh
no you're not one of these things is not
like the other maybe two of these things
is also not like the other fish can ask
you the same question we're not shooting
underwater what are you talking about
well you're crazy man yeah don't don't
be crazy
wait oh wait jack is it time for school
yes it's exactly lead me to them oh you
didn't know you didn't raise this little
black fish right here I don't have a
pistol why don't I have a pistol this
seems like a disadvantage for us to tell
me Jack's a goldfish Jack's over here
you don't
fish in the water float and they were
all floating the drunk fish swimming
floating would be on top yeah yeah yeah
yeah today we have deficient swim
bladders and they don't keep us elevated
yeah
that's racist yeah exactly very racist
to think that our swim bladders are in
effective its specious yeah
all right Foxtrot Delta team whiskey
tango up crap all I'm good I'm fine I'm
good yeah let's not do that
I know if you go back in behind you oh
okay you can you can do sorry guys Oh
lag oh we're nowhere to be found
definitely not fish in the water trying
to blend in just like you guys yeah you
[Laughter]
mess up in the building tell me mark
just relax
I'm in the tower outside of the without
Jack please
Oh - because they were talking to each
other saying no I'll tell you Yami is a
fish wait a minute is that you're good
you're good you're totally good wait how
the hell
seriously Yami how the hell did you just
do that I can't believe you're like
sitting on me that was the plan I didn't
I didn't even think that I could have
been okay Jack here's the game plan
you go left I'll go right we split up
you stay as far away from me as possible
because I'm good at this game in your
bed oh you're terrible you guys should
do that yeah got it got it got it sounds
like Jack is supremely confidence Jack
do you got that's the question
there might be a thing that I have and I
got it and you got it is what you're
saying got it oh it's in the bag there
are several bags and I have them all
inside okay of all the bags yeah oh by
GAD exactly not really I'm not that good
I think jack is Opie I think he's I
think he's lying
I think I'm not a fish I would say that
Oh God can you become that yes probably
maybe I don't know what is everything oh
my god into machines in fright I know
what I'm gonna be next round bob has
some medicine
I've got I've got pro plans this is what
Bob always does he doesn't write I don't
really give a [ __ ] if I find you guys I
just want to come up with good plans so
it's always the next round for market hi
good well he knows he's gonna win
because he always we always end up
[ __ ] up in one way or second Bob and
didn't know that he was there that's not
my fault
that's Bob small that's pretty cold
hearted man yeah all right so was that a
bad way are you god damn it what's that
bags thing a hint or are you just no no
no no that was just from what I was
saying okay
he's a sellout bag bag of dicks that's
what Jack is no what fish I would say
that you know fish so I spent the last
three minutes trying to have fish wait
when you go near them wow I see you Yami
oh you're such a ding dong where are you
we sound I can tell us that's out I
think that is not like you didn't aunt
people by making a sound yeah why didn't
you do that I don't want to do that no
you know I'm so confident I'll do that
over here don't let me all right what
are you what do you press to do that F
am I not doing it I don't understand
doing it right now
hear anything just scream into your
microphone to taunt that's what you got
to do jack we're underwater we have to
make it sound like a rule this would be
a very boring episode
okay I'll give a hint I am very heavy
I'm feel heavy I'm very very heavy so
heavy you sink I'm heavy yeah yeah yeah
so you're a barrel no no you don't know
that Bob that's quite a leap to make you
know I kinda round what I'm scared it's
it's almost hey wait a minute
oh god oh I've made a bad decision
Amy no part of you done wait I lost
health by changing props well I mean you
get some props have more health than
others ah mark is so heavy that he sinks
I'm confused
yeah how are are you currently sunken no
you don't see me okay literally jumped
up right in my face that was already
unfortunate don't understand
buyers have lots of help yeah I had like
108 health so go dig more than there to
kill me
oh no this prop is not as fun as I had
thought it would be no but I thought it
was a whole thing and it's only a we
have to work together so if you over
there okay how do I look yummy oh my god
is incredible is it I don't think it's
as incredible as you think they are
never gonna find you stop
yup you're on our team now we kill you
I'm not a shark I got a shark wait I
think he is in this place
because we heard strange
[Laughter]
I don't think he's a fish I wish I could
see what was happening I can't see
anything but I'm sorry hurt you guys
leave you good boy he was definitely not
in there I know he's gone he was
definitely not in there
wait a minute my [ __ ] was that wait what
Hey what what is it huh
see see mark you see sorry what the hell
are you sure but I'm not a rock jock was
a sign my triangle Rock I thought I
[Laughter]
looked through the glass and I saw a
perfect triangle and I was like I know
that shape I've been laughing I haven't
been able to find a thing give you a few
more heads
he says it all are you good no go check
oh my gosh who you dick I didn't see
anyone how showing me no mercy lush
round and if any bikes are very wide cuz
I couldn't fit through you no mercy last
Road you were a shark
alright what's the strategy yami yeah
Jack I have a feeling that all of our
bombastic nature and braggadocious a
weight equivalent yeah we're very low
cuz we're actually very [ __ ] how's that
people didn't tell me before right
everyday don't worry about all right I'm
confident you'll never find us hey
that's not what I say you say that I say
I do
you'll never find owned try to put words
in my mouth I know what I say alright
Jackie are you checking underwater
yeah I'm checking the northern perimeter
I'm gonna keep an eye out there mark
yeah do you see any way up see you too
I've told them you can get yummy you
know that that tells them where we are
I didn't mean to do that please hurry
right anything
[Laughter]
[Music]
really pro yeah you were both I didn't
even realize I know you are right there
through everything up question you
actually didn't do anything Yami just do
that like when you stay still for too
long no no I don't know stop fighting it
I can hear it yes it's over
totally host right now no we're not
I make sure to press anything and I'll
be alright
just good but when you get scared turn
on your flashlight okay
yeah okay alright you keep looking down
here I'm gonna look above I'm around
okay fish out of water
he's left out of water I should become a
shock again I was so effective yeah last
time seconds becoming a shark how's that
[Laughter]
I want to get out a minute he's he's not
a shark whoever just checked out the
shark yeah I thought he was gonna head
towards it really still after all I
can't believe you escaped after you
taunted when we were on top of each
other
couldn't hear it underwater I don't know
when we were boxes though we were
literally on each other and Mark didn't
kill us I don't know how that happened I
love you like I was sure us though why
don't have your name we don't have
grenades in this mode thank God oh yeah
he's around Oh yummy keep talking so
great operon the other day it was like a
Spanish soap opera no wait what I was
being pushed I was being pushed down by
something he was a plant we tied the
score alright yet good round no it's not
what won us the round I'm just what do
we do jack I have a I have a plan
follow me really yeah I do I promise I
have a plan follow me ten seconds
everyone you're on your own screw you
I'm good I'm good yeah solid solid as a
rock
I'm good two minutes five minutes go
away come here stop being dick
yeah Amir you
I wish you could see the genius of my
hiding spot
it is literally so good it is so
unbelievably good I can see I can
spectate him dead yeah okay well now
that you can see it you can appreciate
the magnitude of my genius in the spouse
huh connect free camera like yes press
spacebar times yeah oh yeah the absolute
impact you pull that trick before you
left the gate open idiot no I didn't
[Laughter]
[Music]
I've got an idea for myself we don't
know we do not well I mean this lag like
when I go in so I only have like 10
seconds left before I can actually start
moving okay we're actually gonna work
together Jack we got to get this okay
I'm gonna go first yeah I'll follow you
I'm usually a leader follow you I'll
follow you I'm following I don't know
this map well enough to see what's out
of place yeah well apparently I don't
either because I don't know Bob knows I
wish I could stand still I've got a
funny spot but I can't stand steel
because you're a fish underwater and
you're floating everywhere alright I
think I'm just taking a dip man I'm not
doing anything
hey I see you over there running up the
up not going up the stairs I see what
you're doing that's what the who's the
real fish in the aquarium here no no no
it's okay it's okay just got my head
above the water over here bothers
viewers I thought I might be submerged I
wanted to try it
yeah that's good it's pretty good pretty
good he's not bad no no mattify me okay
probably will never find all direct
they're not even close right now so
you're pretty safe even if your spot is
kind of lame that's cuz I you followed
my lead I did that was true yeah I've
got six kills I need six kills did
better than all of you I did so alright
fine whatever I'm on Bob's team Bob
we're gonna be on a team together right
the contrary okay is everyone ready
yeah all right looks like props okay do
one click it click okay we're not team
UK hey guys America Island isn't part of
the UK you can count okay Ruby team
Island our ivory Lincoln's team island
nation yeah team that side of the world
T Omar that's my strategy
oh well all right you be there I'll just
stand out in the open and take the
bullets for you because I love you okay
okay there we go
ass work that's getting it yeah that's
the stuff right there okay yeah you you
English and Irish people don't
understand the cornfields of America
like me and Bob do ya know please work
corn grown Americans yeah exactly
actually Bob did grow up in like a
cornfield or something not literally but
yeah yes I grew up in a tent in a
cornfield in fact raised by corn he's a
wild clothes
I was left of my own and when I was 2
months old and raised by the cornfield
I'm really really into not being eaten
by bugs you know children of the corn
that's talking about Bob exactly
oh I would hear Talent yeah into a taunt
that me
I didn't talent is everyone turn that
[ __ ] off I didn't do nothing okay no no
that was played here dancing shut up
there's nothing I think is like just to
make things happen appropriately I guess
it's an interesting mechanic because it
shakes things up quite a bit yeah well
we always have they always move rule
anyway nor work turn around a little
turn around
all right you look pretty good anyway
thank you I know they've walked right by
me like a bunch of idiots I can't have
that they are they just leave for you
alone yeah corn stalks here have a corn
hint because I don't even check the
house yet too late yeah mark that's
pretty funny yeah you can't go in the
house that's not part of the map from
the best you made me write no Wade I'm
pretty sure would jump over a three-foot
fence
yeah this sucks it's a really tense
fence all right I will you can't go in
the house
but you guys haven't checked inside the
trailer yes they try to do it open yeah
inside it I got this yummy watch [ __ ]
LoJack else what's up beer backs all
over this do you see anything bad okay
there's a minute
there's about a minute left I'll give
you a hint I have something to do with
something that horses only place where
there's a hay bale not saying that I am
hey but that's one of them is so
precariously stacked in one of the
locations where yes at the beginning of
the level Bob and I said Bob said that's
my spot
[Music]
trailer you don't know that well maybe
we rely at ten seconds on you should
look near the silos left left should
look for a small silo two silos on the
form marked a few times table team lies
see Jackie's not just these Americans
are you serious I'm stuck do you have
grenades we do oh we have throwable
grenades on your ass or you have a
possible grenade yeah not quite as
effective as the I'm not saying anything
are you one with the corn you want corn
boy likes me Mac you need to get back
your hat and your mustache I have have a
top hat over here is that good enough
oh yeah sucks that I can't pick up sound
I think we were just right next to
someone marked because they made
hilarious that Oh yummy
feeling oh hey wait a second whoa huh oh
hey no I don't think that was it hey no
betting it is that what you guys doing
oh my
oh I saw move it maybe I didn't see
moving maybe I'm lying Bob I might have
been I might a bullcrap or I might have
totally been wrong okay you stay here
and check this area I'm gonna check the
other I don't know why that suddenly
happens randomly guys yeah that didn't
happen to you and you were sentenced
there last time yeah I think it's just
like it's just a random thing that
happens okay it's cause I was too good
that's why yeah it was like yeah they're
never gonna find this guy let's uh they
come over yeah he obviously like made
this level awesome yes Jesus oh you say
my spot isn't good
no I'm saying they're very very stupid
oh we're stupid oh I see he was one of
these yellow barrels but he was right
here he was in a believable spot I don't
know Matt I could have sworn I thought I
thought I thought I thought you didn't
you stood next to him yeah cuz you did
see okay super hard now I'm this now
okay good yeah objects hidden in stupid
locations no no I don't know that you
try hasn't that every round we ever play
I'm gonna survive until my stupid taunt
triggers
[ __ ] you can't pick up the stuff
either when you're a hunter anymore
no that's kind of annoying actually
stuff like on the ground that's low down
and I thought bumping into them would
work but I don't even think the name
pops up when you highlight over them
nope so uh I have no idea where you are
mark but I feel confident but I'm mobile
this round
oh you're allowed I'll keep an eye out
cuz I'm in a perfect spot I ain't going
nowhere
Thanks wrong bones a were interesting
just wrong what wha
strong eyeball wait wait wait wait wait
hmm I told there are no ting
yeah there's night aunt I really loud
we very quiet Frank yeah vitamin me I
don't know why but might have been me
that was Jack okay god I I'm not pushing
the Tahoe whatever you doing mark do it
well hey what hey what hey what what
what what the hell hey-ya Bob what am i
I really hit the spacebar I still don't
know what you are alright that was no
such an obvious hint and I I haven't
moved so I'm still there you glitched
yeah i glitched through the outside of
the map I turned out no cliff on my
secret-spy
oh I was on the top shelf though jumped
over that's what he's doing
oh I jump on the stool and then jumped
up there wrong no guess stupid genius
good our thing is killing me that was a
good spot give me hints and it would
have been hilarious wide I tried to lead
him away with taunts in the other area
okay so jack is the bucket I'm
officially a genius
oh what a see the extent of Yummy's
genius my knowledge has no boundaries
I'll see if you truly are you will never
find me until the tongue goes off is
that at all I hear already all right Oh
Yami Yami feels really good
oh you didn't change okay they will
never find me wait what did you do yeah
I didn't do anything
wait wait what prop was you he was perry
the paint man he bails Wow okay cool
I thought use the same thing as me for a
second no no no I'm saying you didn't
change from what you were at the sir
yeah I just
this is good I don't I don't want to
change it good just lay around
we'll never find me just lay in the hay
oh yeah right yeah oh yeah you're really
misleading us I are you you are so good
at this game and always says that
predator oh yeah you know good in the
notes predator yeah yeah you remember
editor is
oh yeah almost that was pretty good
that's someone snoring not the same you
know predator right at or noise noise
engage all right you have no idea what
we're doing yeah I don't either I was
taking his hint to heart
but I think that was stupid yeah yeah
very stupid you guys lie to me like
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
I never saw him I think he bumped oh
there is always a case of beer I got an
idea mark yeah tell me if this looks
okay wait okay you can Lima that doesn't
that look okay the lighting is off on
that go over to this one oh how do I
look here no matter we come find you
how about that how did you do that
rostro no no don't do that oh good oh
snap cross something oh oh lay on top of
something so good highest point on the
map good luck [ __ ] yeah this oh gosh
leave some skill I'm surprised we
wouldn't be cheating we're in the within
the bounds of the area with but within
the batter in the bounds they're just
really high up no no no no
while you never let I went to the
cornfield baby I'm out of here but
curious if if they taunt do we if they
hit their Tom Bunn do we go alright no
no and why I keep taunting hey I'm a
guard I'm gonna hit F cuz I don't know
Marik's taunts are like that the guard
taunts thoughts okay it's just like a
singular thing it's not a song oh
kidding me I just I just want you smell
what I smell boys bad boys
you guys didn't actually know I was one
of those barrels until I taunted did you
know I did I saw you through the grenade
over there but then I dodged it
you just didn't you just didn't die
promise whatever
whatevs what other oh my gosh shoes I
don't know your feet are a little this
is an old school stuff yeah I know
Internet 1.0 yeah that is such horseshit
so that I can be here but I gotta turn
the volume down so that yes in [ __ ]
video it happens
to me that's perfectly there then Yami
I'm sorry
actually sorry yeah I don't know it's so
crowded is that even 32 props using
props can we be a cornstalk that'd be
amazing
oh yeah that wouldn't be hard to find
yeah be a fence until the toll goes up
next okay next round I'm gonna be the
house [ __ ] me over at the entire games
trying to [ __ ] me over a tick you Jeb Oh
Oh easy easy easy easy now easy Bessie
this time I think I'm in a good spot so
I've heard all right I have no faith in
you Bob but I believe have faith in
myself either all right come on now I
can do this can you can you really I
don't know why you're selling psyching
yourself up or what you're setting
yourself up for things something's in
the cornfield I think I just saw
something no just right yeah I'm not in
the cornfield and I can see you right
now on top of the trailer jack I am in
the cornfield and I cannot see anyone No
mmm what happened nothing here taunt I
think that's them that's them
yeah that's us we're music they're just
radio chatter no I'm hearing radio dots
that's them me apparently that's us for
some reason
I mean I'm hearing music kant's I'm
hearing like Oh song on the radio that's
what I think that's just in your head I
just having flashbacks
shouldn't be long now just wait for it
bad boys
I prefer the party one yeah bombastic
with you that just can't wait to party
spot so good oh it was a sound Jack what
happened did you not hear it nothing
happened it was someone than me there
was a sound that's creepy
you're creepy your face is creepy you
saw I'm coming for you my wait wait Poli
sir where's the [ __ ] time come on
perfectly that is amazing I didn't do
anything
I think smaller you are eventually it
just happens wait what I think I have
like a thousand and a half helped oh so
you are kidding me yeah yeah have fun
shoot away [ __ ] don't dawdle nope
your thoughts you know you gonna have to
do better than that
how'd you get slams there think we have
them automatically
I want to use Slams there's such
[ __ ] for a mode like this yeah just
like set off a trap plot and blown the
hell up he's not even this is he so
awesome so that's gonna be really good
yeah ouch yeah oh oh oh no I believe in
here I've only got three I know he's
there no he's there keep hitting just
really wail on him
their music is actually like legit
coming from this you know why I got
friends you've been trying to hit a
thing you haven't been hitting the wall
behind yeah oh yeah there you go on the
side over there that's the one I'm the
one in the back the one in the back yeah
that's okay you [ __ ]
too smart jack was fooled too until he
got a better vantage point somewhere
where he could see me yeah I don't know
what to be I just love how how long you
tried to wail on that step I can one of
these might kill me but I guess we'll
see what happens oh we do have Slams
yeah they're [ __ ] all right all
right so what I'm gonna do Bob is I'm
gonna I'm gonna lay out lay out some
slams that's not a glitch do that ping
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna mine off
this area so if they come through then
going nowhere it's it is it don't you
have said mom oh yeah I got it I got it
so all I gotta do is flush him out sure
we have a very particular set of skills
didn't make me no uh props like you I
don't know who you are so I can't
believe no one has tried to get up here
as a prop yet stop doing that Bob just
play game
I wasn't looking for myself I was
assuming every round I was assuming
someone would try and get up there no
one has it so we've been come on
everywhere we've gone I think it would
be too obvious if we went up there
somebody shootin are you shootin I mean
I'm at around this time cuz [ __ ] those
taunts
into my slams I think they didn't go off
I am mark no they don't go off
automatically I gotta go I gotta trigger
them wait hello ah I just keep running
around it I keep seeing stuff laying in
the open it's like that doesn't seem
right
why do we always die you straight away
and they don't it says we're awesome
yeah that thing the thing that Bob said
where I know I didn't Bob is that Bob's
the MVP a problem the pro for once in my
life I'm not sucking at this game yeah
Bob is almost too hot oh is that drunk
Irish uncle I don't know what the
[ __ ] woods Oh Oh command that person
see me yeah oh yeah it was in the
cornfield somewhere fresh tomorrow now
you shot my slam you Oh mom not kill Bob
I saw someone chasing after I don't know
how they missed me I just did like a
loop around them school they haven't
reached advanced courses of juking I
didn't really do that much either I kind
of just ran around I didn't even see you
to begin with so I still still your
fault track still your fault shut up I'm
said jacked your skirt see a slum Jack
because I thought it was him yeah Bob
Wow Bob yeah how am I uh well not very
but good enough for them I guess all
right good
you're dumb your face so yummy you
almost got made a complete fool
oh no it it can't hurt us no definitely
not
[Music]
[Laughter]